So this is the essence of Bayes' rule, which I'll give to you in a second.
There is some sort of a prior,
by which we mean the probability before you run a test.
And then you get some evidence from the test itself.
And that all leads you to what's called a posterior probability.
Now this is not really a plus operation.
In fact in reality it's more like a multiplication.
But semantically what Bayes Rule does is it incorporates some evidence
from a test into your prior probability to arrive at a posterior probability.
So let's makes this specific.
In our cancer example we know that the prior probability of
cancer is 0.01 which is the same as 1%.
The posterior of the probability of cancer given that our test says positive,
abbreviated here as positive,
is the product of the prior times our test sensitivity.
Which is, what are the chance of a positive result given that I have cancer.
And you might remember this one was 0.9, or 90%.
Now, just to warn you, this isn't quite correct.
To make this correct we also have to compute the posterior for
the non-cancer option.
Written here is not cancer, given a positive test.
And that's using the prior.
We know that P of Not C is 0.99.
It's 1 minus P of C.
Times the probability of getting a positive test result given Not C.
Realize these two equations are the same but exchange C for not C.
And this one over here takes a moment to compute.
We know that our test gives us a negative result if it cancer free, 0.9 chance.
And as a result it gives us a positive result in
the cancer free case with 10% chance.
Now, what's interesting, is that this is about the correct equation.
Except the probabilities don't add up to 1.
To see, I'm going to ask you to compute those.
So please give us, give me the exact numbers, for
the first expression, and the second expression, written over here.
Using our example up here.